[Music]  please welcome chris man  [Applause]  in this life that we all travel  there are scars and there are battles  where we roam  when we are lost  or wherever we  may go  they will always  [Music]  that have led me to  another  to a friend or to a lover  i have known  for every turn  is a year that i have grown  as i walk  [Music]  [Music]  and some will  [Music]  you will find your way  as you walk  along  these  roads  there were times  when i stumbled and i wondered  but  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  i won't fear  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you will find your way  as you walk along  these roads  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  me  me  [Music]  [Applause]  wow  i think that went well  chris mann ladies and gentlemen great  job nice to see you again